It's been just under three weeks since I
uploaded my 10,000 subscriber's thank you
video. Now here we are at the momentous
100,000 milestone. A lot of people have
asked for a behind-the-scenes look at how
I make my videos. Before we get started,
let me just take a moment to thank all
of you amazing people for sticking with
Second Thought and supporting the
channel. I'm also going to use this video
as a Q&A, so if you have a question that
I haven't answered by the end of the
video, leave me a comment below and i'll
respond to you as quickly as I can.
Now, on to the main event. Every Second
Thought video starts as a simple idea;
When something interests me, I write it
down on my ever-expanding list of video
topics. At any given time, I have about
two or three months worth of videos to
choose from.
Once I have picked the topic I want to use, it's
time to research. It's amazing how many
scholarly resources you can find with
just a simple google search, scientific
journals and study reports are my
favorite resources, because they provide
raw data without imparting significant
bias. I'll take note of the source, and then
synthesize the information into short
notes before moving on to the next one.
Once i have enough notes, I'll throw in a
dash of my brilliant Second Thought
brand humor and draft up my script.
A couple read-throughs to make sure it
flows nicely, then it's time to record
the audio. I'm going to let you in on a
big secret - You don't need a fancy
recording studio to get decent quality
audio. Wanna see my studio? Here it is:
My closet! All the fabric helps absorb
unwanted noise, which is perfect for
recording clean audio. As for hardware
I use a Zoom H5 recorder with a shotgun
microphone attachment to make sure I only
capture my voice without any background
noise. It usually takes me about 20
minutes to get everything recorded to my
standards. From there, I'll head over to
my computer to edit the audio. I'll put a
link to pcpartpicker.com if you want
to see the exact parts I used for my build,
but here are the big points: the i7 6700k,
Superclocked GTX 1070, 16 Gigabytes DDR4 RAM
and a 500 Gigabytes solid-state drive,
operating system and the adobe suite
Aaand Battlefield.
I'm no sound engineer, but I'm very
familiar with Adobe Premiere, which is
adequate for simple trimming of audio files.
I'll take about an hour to go through
and trim out noticeable breaths and pauses,
as well as the sound of muffled crying
when I mess up a sentence for the
fifteenth time. Once that's done, I'll export it
as a high-quality MP3 and save it for later.
Now, I have two different ways to make
the actual video and it all depends on
how proactive I am in the days leading
up to the upload. If I'm good, I'll open
my script and Photoshop side-by-side and
draw the assets I'll need for the video
before I even open AfterEffects.
More often than not though,
I will just draw as I go. In that
case, I'll have AfterEffects open with
Photoshop minimized and when I need a
new character or drawing, I will pull up
Photoshop, draw it,
export it as a PNG file and then import it
into AfterEffects. For drawing, I use a
Wacom Intuos tablet. It's nothing
fancy - I think I paid about 80 bucks for it -
but it gets the job done and it's
never given me any trouble. From there,
I'll just sit in my terribly
uncomfortable walmart chair and edit for
about 10 or 12 hours straight until the
video is done. And that's it!
It's a lot of hard work, but it's so
rewarding to finish a video and know you did
a good job.
I'll refine my setup when I'm able and
hopefully I will be able to put out even
better videos in the future. Again, I
couldn't do this without the support of
all you fantastic people. Your comments
never fail to brighten my day and it's
incredibly rewarding to see our
community grow the way it has.
Together, we'll make Second Thought one for the
history books!
Remember to ask any questions you have
down below in the comments.
Thanks for watching and I'll see you in the next video!